the Joe Rogan experience they try
everything to scare marijuana smokers
why why is that they should just smoke
weed and get their dick sucked
they would change the way they feel
about all this they'd be like I can't
believe blowjobs feel so good
do-do-do-do-do-do from someone who loves
you who tickles your balls when you come
in their mouth hey while you're high
cheese just glue eases okay they don't
know about that do they know about that
because if they do you know I would
imagine if you're the way the sheriff of
Greenlee knows about that if you're a
girl and you smoke a couple hits of weed
and then get your pussy licked that's
got feels so good could you imagine like
a shower feels good when you're high
yeah imagine how good it feels for girl
get your ass licked do I like my ass
listen this is like a fill out form for
a fucking gangbang video okay now do you
like it in your ass right because if yes
check the box to the right that should
never come up you should go from you
cradle to the grave without anybody ever
asking you do you like in your ass light
or maybe maybe that should be it that
should be a fun thing about a funeral is
you have to write the answer yes or no
like on a piece of paper and then have
it in your hand like when you're dead
did you check his note that was a yes
with two exclamation points the problem
with the question like do you like your
ass licked is that's not how anybody
ever asks it if they're gonna lick your
ass right they don't go do you like to
get your ass licked they don't say that
they would say you want me lick your ass
oh you do huh they would have a lot of
hugs in there like let me lick your ass
huh you do like they already affirming
it because it's a risky thing to say
like your ass huh
you know that's like you want that
person to have an easy time saying yes
you fucking sick fuck fuck you I tricked
you asshole right right the bedroom
opens up the camera crew comes in you've
been on the new show do you want your
ass flame then it becomes like a big
court case where they try to figure out
what what huh means when you add Han to
it and the lawyer tries to defend it
clearly if she used the word huh she was
she was trying to get a positive
affirmation out of him she was
manipulating his emotional responses the
natural responses of a person he was
doing it to be polite he didn't really
want his ass licked okay he didn't want
her to feel bad she said huh already
okay what as it was happening he was
realizing he had made a mistake yeah you
know it'd be like joining an army that
thinks they're gonna go out and fight
Bigfoot like you got all your fucking
gear you really good mountains like we
are the Sasquatch and he'd be like Oh
what have I done what if I done I can't
believe I'm gonna go there's an army of
people I've joined fuck I made a mistake
shit yeah you can't pull out of it
that's what's got to be like it's crazy
well that's where you you know you're
known for not just being one of the
pioneers of MMA but you're known for
that expression yamato damashii that you
have always you've always promoted that
ideal this this samurai spirit and this
the spirit of Japan this way of of doing
things
wholeheartedly and you know you've
talked openly that you freely give
yourself like when you would go to fight
you would be ready to die yes and not
just saying that like you
you'd really reconciled it in your mind
you would say goodbye to your friends
say goodbye to your family letters yeah
I wrote letters to people that I wanted
to say goodbye to every fight yeah
that's some deep shit yeah you know but
the thing too is um fighting to die
trying to die you're gonna train with
the will to die too so you can see
almost good training I got yeah
I mean I'm training every day before the
fight so I won't die in the fight I'm
planning I'm okay I'm accepting the fact
that I might die there but I know that
the better I can be is the less chance
to me dying in the ring so you know I'm
not gonna get up in the morning and
because I'm sorry I'm not gonna miss
training because I'm tired or I'm lazy
because it'll might be the difference in
me living and dying in the ring so you
know it helped me out a lot in that in
the training aspect and you know the
dieting I mean I want to eat only drink
a coke but I'm trying to eat only good
things on my before my fight and it's
it's a lot easier to do that when you're
in to that level
it can't hurt you you know to plan to
die in the ring to believe that and to
train and to walk that life for that
three months while training for the
fight it they can't hurt you is it
difficult for you because you earnestly
embrace that thought process is it
difficult for you when you see guys that
are kind of dabbling in MMA they're kind
of like half-assing it not training hard
enough maybe they have some talent but
they don't really put their will and
heart into it well it's a whole new era
now yeah because back in the day we
didn't get paid good we were we weren't
weird that worried about you know losing
a sponsor here right being caught by the
UFC you know that kind of stuff didn't
because there's all these little
association we're fighting for us a
little bit money the objective and the
the the whole movement of that era was
different yeah so you know when fighters
start getting lazy you know what they
don't fight as hard or they tap out a
little sooner you know I understand that
because it's a whole new era because
you're fighting for a different reason
now they're fighting for money they're
fighting for living there fighting for
sponsors they're fighting to look good
you know so it's easier when you're
fighting for those reasons I mean
there's only so much money will make you
do mmm
but if you're fighting for your honor
and you're fighting for your life it's a
whole different level yeah so